blown away by not only the combine but
watching him on film as another level
he's one of the best running backs I've
ever seen in my life on film I was blown
away I just watched this morning he's
better than fournette or Ezekiel eeeh
coming out the last two years he's
better than those two and I can't
believe I'm saying that either he is in
the discussion for one of the best
running backs I'd ever seen coming out
of college he's worthy of the number one
pick in the draft he is in the open
field he does things that I've never
seen anybody do he's got like LeSean
McCoy type quicks except he's faster and
more explosive and more powerful I mean
he's got a perfect body the crew like
epitome of what you want from an NFL
modern-day running back he's like
Ezekiel Elliott with like a levee on
bail mixed in and Alice Sean McCoy
altogether quicker and faster than David
Johnson his route running is
extraordinary extraordinary he's
basically Todd Gurley except he's bigger
and faster and quicker Berkeley is on a
different planet than almost any running
back in the history of the sport